nous sommes en forêt départementale de
mairie dont qui se situe sur les
communes de chevreuse de saint rémy les
chevreuse et de choisel si une forêt 289
hectares qui s'est en partie sur le
plateau d'i moore est en partie sur le
coteau sud de l'yvette et qui domine la
vallée de chevreuse et c'est ici que
vous pourrez découvrir le compte de
melide à l'esprit de la forêt ils se
dévoilent le long d'un parcours de
quelques centaines de mètres et commence
par ces mots un atteindre une e martin
jeunes du front se rendaient dans la
forêt de mairie dont pour son premier
jour de travail
alors qu'ils s'apprêtaient à abattre son
tout premier arbre il entendit une voix
inconnue est inquiète es tu sûre de
vouloir couper ce chêne c'est à travers
plusieurs panneaux que se raconte
ensuite l'histoire de ce bûcheron et de
melide à une promenade aménagée à
l'initiative du département des yvelines
une invitation à la rêverie en forêt qui
se conclue par quelques notes de musique
et en arrivent aux oeuvres musicales aux
sculptures sonores qui sont réalisés en
bois donc là c'est le xylophone on
appelle aussi le piano de bois il est
entièrement en chaîne et chacune des
planches donne une note bien précises ce
qui fait qu'on on peut jouer une petite
mélodie sur le piano plusieurs
réalisations de will menter artiste
anglais anciens musiciens sont ainsi
accessibles au public une façon
originale de découvrir le site de mairie
dont et d'en savoir plus sur sa faune et
sa flore il était de proposer quelque
chose en entrée de sites et de faire
rêver et d'interpeller le promeneur de
façon originale voilà c'est quelque
chose qui est assez qui est peu courant
encore de commencer sa visite par un
compte et ça permet de toucher tout type
de public bien sûr un public familial
les enfants des plus petits jusqu'aux un
peu plus âgées mais aussi un public
adulte parce qu'en fait ça réveille en
nous notre notre âme d'enfant donc c'est
vraiment accessible à tout le monde le
parcours est ouvert toute l'année depuis
l'automne dernier et mettra vos cinq
sens en éveil